I'm sorry everyone.
Hello everybody.
Hello.
Oh my god.
I'm sorry guys.
I'm sorry everyone.
Um.
I don't know what happened.
Okay.
Basically.
Uh.
Oh my god.
I didn't even tweet a waiting room.
Um.
any room okay so wait did i yes i did i did no i didn't no i
did oh my god oh okay okay here's here's what happened it's
because you guys must be like why did she nap at six i'm so
sorry everyone i feel so bad because like ever since i came
back from the vacation it's been so messy it's been
um okay so this is what happened um i was really tired at 7
a.m 7 p.m i was really fucking tired because like i said
i've been trying to catch up with all my work stuff since uh
uh you know all the work stuff because of past dokey and i'm
still catching up um and then so i was really tired and i
went to bed i went and took a nap at six 7 or 7 p.m.
And then I woke up at 11 p.m.
I woke up at 11 p.m.
And I was like, okay, well, obviously, I can't fall back
asleep because it's 11 now.
So, and I worked until 7 a.m.
And then I was like, I'm going to go take another nap
because I'm like, I should take another nap before the
stream, at least.
And then, like, so then I didn't think I was going to sleep
that much because I was like, it's 7 a.m.
There's no way I'm going to sleep past 5 p.m.
Maybe I'll wake up at 3 or 4 p.m.
Because I already had another nap at 7 p.m.
Like, I had a 4-hour nap at 7 p.m.
So there's no way.
Because if I did sleep past 5, that would be 11 hours.
I would have slept 11 hours.
So, like, in my head, I was like, there's no way I need an
alarm.
There's no fucking way.
That's like, there's no way I'm going to be asleep for 11
hours.
There's no way.
And then it
was...
Neppers, thank you for the Akka Supa.
Thank you, thank you.
Hi, Toki.
It's my birthday.
Next week, you can get a very sleepy, happy birthday from
the one and only FPS.
YouTuber Donky Brittle, of course, Nepers, of course!
Happy birthday to you!
Happy birthday, dear Nepers!
Yeah!
Happy birthday!
And thank you again for the Aka Supa!
Thank you, thank you!
I don't... I don't know.
I just... I don't know what the fuck happened, guys.
I really don't know what the fuck happened and I legit was
like there's no way I'm gonna I feel so bad though for
everyone that waited an hour for me and was like like ever
since I came back from vacation my sleep has been like all
over the place I didn't and I feel so fucking bad um making
you guys wait for an hour in between don't wait because I
thought there's no there's no way I was just like there's
there's no way I won't I won't need an alarm I just I don't
remember the dream at all I just knew it was like super
intense because when I woke up I was like what the fuck what
the fuck was that dream and then I literally saw the alarm
and then I forgot all about the dream like I mean I saw my I
saw what time it is and everything I dreamed about whatever
the fuck I was dreaming I don't even remember I was just
like freaking out because I was just Oh my god, it's 530
Why did it get to 530?
I was panicked and then my brain deleted the dream While I
wasn't looking Yeah, the ins I was, oh my, alright, anyway,
let's go Let's play Halo I don't know how long today's gonna
be Like I said, I think I need like I still need some more
catch I still have some more stuff to do It doesn't end Ah,
damn it.
I haven't played video games other than on stream.
I haven't played any offline gaming.
All I've been doing is just work.
Damn you, Bastokie.
Damn you to hell.
A cycle continued.
My manager actually was like, also the reason why my manager
didn't wake me up, he was like, you know, in the past of a
half almost over slept um he'll wake me up was that uh my
manager is from eu so even i bet he even he was like there's
no way she's not gonna wake up like because when i stream at
five he's asleep so then he i think he was like there's no
way she's not she's not gonna wake up before her stream
she's gonna take a lot like there's no way so then he didn't
think he had to wake me up before he went to bed.
Like, right.
The last little bit of faith he had.
He'll be fine.
And yeah, she'll be fine.
He underestimated.
I underestimated myself.
I'm going to start setting up alarms until my sleep is
fixed.
I thought I fixed it too, but I was so I was so fucking
tired you don't understand at 7 um I was just at 7 p.m.
I was just so exhausted I was just like I I have to sleep
like I can't get any work done and then I ended up fucking
over my sleep schedule again i think
guys i think okay the reason why like what about dad he's
still at the dog's because i was like i need to fix i need
to fix my sleep schedule before i bring him back and then so
i don't even have the fucking dad alarm to fucking help me
because i'm worried i'm worried that um I'm worried that
like I'm not gonna wake up in time or my sleep is gonna be
even more messed up with him here because um he would bark
and ask me for things when when I'm either for during like
specific times like specific routines and so that's why like
I didn't bring him back yet because I was really worried.
I was really worried that it's going to like mess up with my
sleep even more.
But apparently I might actually need him back to fix my
sleep schedule.
I might actually need him here to fucking fix my sleep
schedule to wake me up.
Because he would have woken me up.
Because like around five is this like feeding time.
Like before I stream is his feeding.
and walkies time and he'd be like bitch fucking wake the
fuck up it's my time now and like oh my god I I just oh my
yeah I don't know how I didn't think I need an alarm guys I
really I really didn't think I would need an alarm wait how
many streams has it been where my sleep has Where I had to
where I didn't fucking show up where I just disappeared.
It was this one It was the members.
It was one of the members stream and then I don't remember
the other one where I was like guys I have to sleep more
Within like two weeks.
Yeah Within two weeks.
So it's like I'm so sorry everyone.
I really it's just my body is betrayed me i don't remember
what the last stream was it was a it was a 12 30 stream
because i was just like i can't do a 12 30 stream at that
time like oh post overwatch it was oh wait never i remember
it was post overwatch i was playing retro rewind because i
the puzzle stream i was on time
stream at least at least all right anyway um all right let's
play halo for real again thank you guys for being so patient
with me i don't know what to do to make up for it right now
um but not legendary not legendary i'm not gonna play
legendary but i'll try and think of something to make up for
it guys i'll be on time for all my streams next week i'll
prove you guys wrong I'll be I'm gonna be on time for all of
my streams next week guys next week that's right I'm gonna
do it good luck if I don't I will let you guys think of a
punishment I know that is like too much power for you guys
but that will motivate me to be on time for all of my
streams that there wouldn't be a punishment
so I'm not scared because I'll be on time for all of my
streams next week so that you and I will have no Shinran and
the plot twist is that I have zero streams scheduled for
next week that's the plot twist
That's the plot twist.
Like, wait a minute.
Wait a minute.
She can't be late if there's no streams next week.
Hey, guys.
I gotta take a vacation.
My little loophole.
But I would actually unsub.
She can't lose if she doesn't stream.
You just had one.
Alright, let's actually play some Halo.
For real.
Alright.
No, but I will promise you guys.
Next week, all of my streams will be on time.
For real.
And if I'm not, you guys can think of a punishment.
But it doesn't matter.
You guys can spend as much time as you want.
To think of a punishment.
It might be a really good.
punishment but you will never see it come to life because I
will be on time next I'll set alarms you'll be like oh it's
501 it's 501 dokey's late dokey that's right he won't catch
me you're not even gonna catch me because I'll start at 5 Or
1230.
Jesus combo for punishment.
Zachary, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Everyone remember this moment.
Alright, let's see.
Forward, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Rabbit pointing at the fucking clock.
Oh, oh, oh.
No!
All right, let's see.
Doki Barrel and Time Streaming Challenge.
Legendary mode.
Go luck.
All the same, Doki.
Getting sleep schedules under control is a task and a half.
Peter, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Thank you for the super chat.
We should start planning the punishments now, guys.
Chunker, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
The punishment should be swimsuit.
Doki.
That's not even a punishment for for me.
I'll do it right now if you want it.
Oh yes, what sexy dokey back?
Guys, because I will do that right now.
That's no punishment.
No, no, no, no.
I didn't wait two hours, like one hour for you to bring her
back.
Don't live.
Listen to that dragonhood.
Kill the heretic leader.
The prophets will be done.
Alright.
There's gonna be the zombies, isn't it?
Wait, it's purple.
Oh, wait, it's green.
Green aliens are good.
Red aliens are bad.
Why is...
Oh, there they are.
are hey hey there i remember you guys hey there yep it's
them they're back oh the zombies green is friendly red is
not bad not good not good sorry red is also not bad red is
bad green is bad No, green is good.
Red is good.
Bad.
They're back.
The flood.
Why do we even keep them?
Are we not supposed to exterminate everyone?
Oh, there they are.
There's the zombies.
Oh, no.
They seem really strong.
Why the fuck did they keep them?
thought we were supposed to exterminate all of them like why
did the heretics keep them why did they keep them
for research they never do they never learn oh oh oh oh oh
green is green is it was purple at first It was purple!
Guys!
It was purple!
Guys, it was purple!
No one told me what purple would be!
Hold your fire!
It seems safe to silence me.
He's using a hollow drill.
Oh.
Wait, but it turned non-holo!
Oh!
I was like, oh my god, he came back.
Okay.
Game volume's kind of low.
This was the original game volume.
Alright, I'm not wasting ammo.
Actually, I shouldn't.
I might as well.
Alright.
I didn't want to waste ammo, but I might have to.
Alright, there's the...
zombies.
Oh, is audio actually low?
It's just poor mixing at that point.
Because that's the same audio I used for yesterday.
Yeah, but then my energy... Oh, wait, maybe I can actually
use it.
There's an extra energy sword right here.
Where are they?
Oh, they're trying to get into those bodies.
Oh, shit!
I was just chopping them up.
I was trying to chop, chop, chop.
The sound got here.
I don't know.
They might have disappeared.
How is he still alive?
I was gonna say, he doesn't even have a head anymore.
How is he still standing?
No head!
What?
He's a zombie!
Oh,
he's hurting me!
A zombie still needs a head, guys.
Oh, there they are.
Oh my god, wait, he actually doesn't have a head.
Oh
No head My guy Don't worry Do it for the covenant covenant
Covenant All right,
I'll be on high ground just in case
Like I don't yeah, I see dead.
I'm pretty sure he's dead dead yet
Oh, they infect around the neck, okay.
Every time they say it's for research, something always
happens.
Just research the dead ones.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, it's okay.
It's the armor.
It's okay.
Oh.
Oh, it's okay.
armor becoming zombie for research it's never a good idea
when they do stuff for research
thank god yeah i know thank god for shields am i right wait
why is there only okay there's three of us wait where's the
white one the white one should be the strongest one they
have the most armor
When did he die?
Where's the white armor, dude?
What do you mean the blue one survived before the white one?
Oh, my God.
He has a gun, and I don't...
What?
Oh, my God.
He...
What?
Okay.
Okay, that was bullshit.
That was a bullshit.
Okay.
There we go.
How fucking strong was he?
I got slapped!
They slapped me back!
Oh, I have to just shoot them.
Oh, no.
I feel like I died to these guys before I died.
Alright, get the defenses out.
There we go.
That's okay.
We have armor.
All right, now there was one.
I think I might have actually slapped the other one.
I...
I might have absolutely slapped a different one.
That was an oopsie on my part.
All right, there we go.
Wait, I hear a lot of stuff.
steps below me i hear a lot of footsteps well bitter patter
below me i don't know if i like that oh okay this just
leaves it okay i was just like who the is downstairs from
downtown
okay all right so i should need more who is he shooting at
why did he shoot oh this guy
It's good that they're cutting down.
I actually need a new guns.
Oh shit!
It's okay.
He has armor.
Wait, he's still alive?
Okay, this one's a strong one.
I actually need more ammo though.
Fuck!
There's two!
Okay, there you go.
All right, now there's one.
Okay, it's fine.
I'm surprised that they stayed alive.
laugh for this long, honestly.
I am very surprised they managed to say a laugh for that
long.
In the end.
They made it this far.
They made it.
I didn't even expect them to make it this far, you know?
So, good job on them.
Oh, what?
I get backstabbed.
Okay.
Okay, buddy.
All right, I'll figure this out.
I need a Zarya beam this.
I gotta move around.
I actually need more of these, too.
Okay.
Oh, oh, okay.
I'm alive.
I was a little scared I was gonna hit something else.
Okay, these beams are really strong against them.
You get another one.
Oh.
Oh, you were pretending.
Oh, shit.
I don't think I was pretending.
Okay, I actually need more of these guns.
There was another one here, right?
I saw another.
Oh, shit.
yeah i actually need another one of the the ray guns there
we okay that's eight bullets that's all right i mean eight
bullets is eight bullets oh okay all right i'll slap first
all right all right 30 i'll take that 30 There we go.
Oh, there goes eight bullets.
Alright.
I mean, they are giving me a couple of guns for days.
Alright, let's grab this.
Alright.
It's a lot of dead bodies.
And I didn't kill.
Which means they're gonna come back to life, aren't they?
Oh, silly little guys.
Don't.
Oh, wait.
I actually wanted this.
Oh.
Oh, shit.
Okay.
Look, there's no color.
There's no color.
Which one's my team?
Okay, they're not...
None of them are my team.
Alright, I'll just let them kill each other.
I'll let them kill each other.
point there's actually no point in me contributing to this
fight none of them that's the funny part don't you they're
all the enemies yeah i figured that out when you know they
both shot me back we'll just watch this one guy die there's
no way he'll see like i'm slowly crawling you're so fucking
stupid all right my turn
All right, my turn.
Okay, you gotta stay still.
Stand still!
Stay still!
My turn.
Don't keep coming in with a third party.
Stay still.
There we go.
Not the plasma rifle.
Oh my god, what?
a fucking he was oh wait what he was terminal
your actions do not make sense proper protocol for a flood
outbreak is to establish immediate infection reporting
communications must be maintained with all local forces in
order to track any spread of the parasite there are no local
forces oracle well now all you have is me but I tracked
multiple ships in orbit including some remaining human
presence but he's back that asshole what the fuck you can
set aside this disagreement with the humans no anything
still alive in orbit is our enemy the humans have very good
cause to kill us i thought i killed this guy and the
knowledge you've shared with me cast doubt on the entire
purpose of our covenant if any of our ships remain above us
they are not the help you seek
because of this talk of prophecies and oh this was the past
oh it's a flashback about your covenant before that reclaim
oh so you knew about the flood but my understanding is
incomplete the AI I encountered on board one of your ships
was less than forthcoming what you need to know Oracle is
that thousands of years ago at the founding of our great
covenant a bargain was struck between the prophets and the
elites a bargain which i feel will be the end of us
okay so he is like the deal was oh my i was watching lord
excuse me okay all right live okay what the okay okay they
came back they fucking came back why weren't you oh the
reinforcements are here now that i know i said oh my god
they're they're the armored ones they have actual armor yeah
this is not gonna do i need them to drop down
don't worry maybe the the the swarm is gonna come back too
yeah i'm gonna have to
there you go kobe
Oh, wait, wait, wait, they're shooting the...
Nice, alright, the swarm are here to help.
Well, to help no one, but, like...
But it's to help me.
No, it's fine.
I need them to shoot the swarm.
I'm going to be third partying.
I'm here to third party, guys.
It's alright.
We wait.
for them to finish the job.
The swarm is easier to kill for some ram.
No, I'll camel later.
See, look at that.
Look at that.
I told you, I finished the job.
There you go.
It was just that easy.
I don't like all these creepy crawly sounds around me.
They're here somewhere.
Oh, hey.
Oh, you need a refresh.
You need a reach.
Oh, fuck!
I just knew it.
I knew you were here somewhere Goddamn little baby parasites
All right Where do I go now?
Oh Goodbye You're still swarming Oh
Oh my god, when they say the swarm, they know that.
The swarm is still swarming, at least we know that.
Wait, what am I getting shot by?
Oh, okay.
They're just like, wait for me.
Okay, okay.
Get me out of here.
I need another gun.
It's that
There we go What he's still alive?
Oh god
It's like and they keep oh my god.
I'm all the way back here.
All right, we got wait.
We have third party again We got third party again I didn't
think Okay, I should have just sniped him It's just really
hard to find a charger here Guys, it's so hard to find a
charger, you know
There we go Okay, we just gotta destroy the bodies If the
bodies are destroyed They can't charge anything
Okay It's like they're flooding the room or something.
Okay, then wave three.
Wave three should come in soon.
Where's the second wave?
Hello?
Oh, checkpoint.
Now it gives me a checkpoint!
Oh, I'm sorry what the fuck didn't walk to the door in time?
Like, oh, now the checkpoint system is so fucking weird.
and sometimes it doesn't.
Now I get the checkpoint.
Oh, I have this gun.
Okay.
What the fuck was the point?
I took like 80 goddamn bullets in one fucking shot.
When you're lonely and safe, checkpoint that was i think
they got researched less on the flood and researched more on
the military budget for the covenant yeah i can cloak but i
know pussy
why cloak when i can shoot back anyway i ran out of bullets
i'm at the start cloaking
good Covenant Pudges Runs on Faith System Why didn't they
pray harder?
Fair.
Why didn't they pray or believe harder?
My prayers did not pay for this.
My prayers did not pay for these guns.
For these nerd research.
Goddamn nerds fucking putting their prayers into goddamn
flood research.
Did you pray today?
My prayer taxes.
We gotta reallocate our prayer taxes to something more
useful.
You're only based on thoughts and prayers.
No faith.
open up where why are the doors not opening where is my
where is my prayer money going to my prayers where are my
prayers going to I demand an answer I demand an answer right
now and door stuff is it this door obviously it's not this
door oh my god are there enemies that got stuck from above?
Oh my god, you!
This fucker!
There we go.
Door unstuck.
Okay, alright, I wish the door was stuck.
Still.
There we go.
Okay, we gotta let these guys...
Let these guys take a bunch of the enemies and then they'll
fight for me.
Surely.
And then we'll have them fight for me.
me.
We'll get rid of the little guys, though.
We'll third party again.
It always works.
Okay, not me!
Turn around!
Turn the fuck around!
There we go.
Yes!
Go!
My children!
Alright, they're dead.
They're dead.
The little kids.
The little kids are dead.
Yeah.
Oh, that's time.
Okay.
How did I get in front of them?
How did I...
All right, this sword sucks.
I swear to God that gets stuck on me.
I swear to God.
There we go.
It's J.
Yeah, fucking I can tell.
All right, I'm in this room now.
Oh, decontamination.
Decontamination?
We cannot maintain our position.
Bring the phantoms close to the mine.
We are not leaving until the leader of these heretics is
dead.
Wait, where are they chasing after?
Oh, these two.
All right, we'll watch.
What the fuck are you coming over here?
For safety?
Oh, okay.
All right.
They can just be...
They can just see invisible.
Oh, they're my guys.
They're my guys.
Green is good.
Green...
That's embarrassing for that guy.
That's why they're the...
of the army.
Green is good.
Red is bad.
See, I told you.
I told you by next stream, I will learn.
I will learn a difference.
I overcome my programming, guys.
Look at that.
I've overcome my military...
Oh my god.
Okay.
Alright, whoops.
I thought I was a big guy.
Oh, no.
I don't have ammo right now.
There we go.
Please stop running.
Okay.
Alright.
Alright, here we go.
Is that...
That's a bad guy, right?
Yeah, that is a bad guy.
Okay.
Where is he?
Wait, oh my god!
What the fuck!
I was trying to find the other guy!
Oh my god.
A fucking quirk.
The goddamn defenses.
Alright.
Yeah, it's fine.
Look at that.
See?
I can change.
Actually might need this, though.
I don't have enough ammo.
He's bad because he's shooting back.
Okay.
Alright, nice.
I don't think they maintain your discipline.
Or my allies again.
They all died to the heretics.
Alright, we'll let them fight it out.
Because I don't know if they're the good ones or the bad
ones.
Oh no, they're definitely the bad ones.
We'll just wait.
We'll wait for their party later.
We'll clean it up.
I'm invisible.
Yes.
Alright.
And now I can't finish the job.
Oh, okay.
We'll leave one of them to take care of these guys.
I need another sentinel beam.
Wait, what the fuck?
He just went through that portal.
That's cheating.
all right nice oh there he is this will save me from the
storm there's the fucking heritage what where is he oh he's
back yeah I was wondering where that guy was botched himself
in tight we'll never break through this then we shall force
him out oh fucking coward cable I'm going to cut it what get
everyone back to the ships it's gonna cut it the orbiter
will continue upward cut this station loose and scare the
heretic from his hole it's gonna cut it to cut the cable
keep your sacrifice keep your blade handy I doubt the cable
can withstand his bite oh no it's free fall time oh no no
where is the cable though it's time to play cut the rope
okay but where is the where is it located oh it's up oh
that's why they gave me all these stairs
i'm gonna cut it i'll just slowly head up
Oh, they're defending it.
Maybe I shouldn't have left.
Okay, I actually might need the ammo for this soon.
Oh, whoops.
This is bad.
I like how these little guys are still trying to chase me.
You do nothing.
You do nothing to me.
Okay, now I only have a knife.
Which is not ideal.
Okay, thank God.
I was going to say, I can't.
and knife this.
Alright, I'm gonna cut it.
Oh, never mind.
I'm gonna start the elevator and then I'm gonna cut it.
What the fuck is the popcorn gonna do?
It's just gonna touch my foot.
Alright, we'll let them play.
I'm gonna find the cable.
What looks like a big-ass cable.
Does any... Oh, there it is!
I see it.
Okay, to be fair, it blends right in if it wasn't for it.
Like, if I look at that, I just see it as a metal pole.
But then when I put it like this, I see a cable.
Oh, no.
Wait.
Wait a minute.
Give me a sec.
It's not fair!
Oh, no.
Oh no, I just need to recharge my shield.
Okay.
How do I cut it?
God.
How do I...
How do I cut this?
Do I just...
Step one.
From behind?
Oh shit, I'm cutting it!
I don't...
Wait, they did it!
I think it's cut.
Do I have to cut it more?
Oh, shit!
Cut.
Cable cut successfully.
Yeah, I'm just going to use my sword.
Who would have thought a sharp knife-y thing would work?
All right, cable number one.
Cable number two.
All right.
I'm going to recharge my sword real quick.
boy.
I got my sword adapter.
Alright, we're learning.
Oh my god, we're leaning to the right.
It's leaning Tower of Covenant.
Alright, nice.
I told you I was gonna cut it.
Alright, time to free fall, guys.
It's gonna be a nice it's like a roller coaster.
Yay!
Oh, oh.
Oh, we're falling a lot faster than I thought we were going
to fall.
Alright.
Gravity!
Yay!
For some reason, I don't think that's how gravity works.
I actually need that gun, though.
Give me...
Who told me to jump?
Who the fuck told me to jump?
What the fuck said jump?
I was like, jump?
Yeah, I'll jump.
Alright.
Why would you listen?
I don't know.
I thought maybe he's something cool.
We're like, we're like, they picked me up.
They picked me.
They're like, here's your ride, Doki.
Oh, now I free fall.
you're gonna be like okay i don't like how this is worse how
does this look worse now
jump up not jump down wait we jump oh wait where do i okay
is it this way where was where did he go okay he went
downstairs there's no fall damage though so we're fine this
way
okay i need your guns though oh shit the little baby lives
the zombies came
The heretic leader is on the move.
Do not let him escape.
Okay, I need one of their guns though.
Alright.
What the fuck do you mean I can't take their guns?
What are my prayer taxes paying for?
Oh my god.
I need like something.
I guess I do have grenades.
Who mean the truth?
I am the truth.
Okay, I know these guys are one shot, so we're fine here.
Oh, wait.
There you go.
Wait, I saw a gun.
Wait, actually, I'll kill this guy first.
This is...
Wait.
Wait, they're gonna have to fight the alien, and now I can
drop...
You do not drop down.
We're keeping pace as best we can Is this not Where is he?
Like, where am I supposed to go?
Do I jump?
I got it!
Okay.
button on the side there was a button oh my god there was a
button there was a button there was this goddamn vangled
alien technology stupid alien technology
yeah i should needed that too i like he just like fucking
slowly drops down okay if it's like are these uh Yeah,
they're the regular aliens.
Okay, they're all aliens.
I'd rather fight the flood than the heretics.
Alright, well...
If it's a fight, if it's a knife fight you want, it's a
knife fight you'll get.
Boom!
That's right!
Give me your knife!
Oh, well, can't take this knife.
Goodbye.
Oh, wait, no.
Wait, no, come back.
I thought that was me.
Come back, you fucking goward.
My knife is stronger.
We all have cloaking devices.
I don't know why he's not using it.
Like, oh, shit.
Not it.
Oh, fuck.
Barrel!
That's right.
exploded each other we okay wait
there's two I'm gonna shot by two different ships that's not
fair all right I need a barrel roll here another barrel roll
here just
film that I can't barrel roll and shoot at the same time
okay and you go all the way over here where the big funny
arrow is
Made it.
My plot armor was simply stronger.
Are there any third party?
Okay, we'll just wait.
We'll just wait.
I know the ship is free-falling, but don't worry.
It's like a million meters away from the ground.
That's fine with me.
There we go.
We'll just wait a little bit.
There's a lot of time before.
we touch the ground.
He's so cool, guys.
Damn.
I need to recharge my sword, I do.
Wait, is he...
Okay, he's a bad alien.
I always have to double check, okay, guys?
I double check before I shoot.
See, in the past, I would be, like, shoot before thinking.
But look at me.
That's character development right there.
And that's what I like to call character development.
I think before I shoot.
Who is this girl?
Who is she?
Not my jokie bird.
She will shoot all aliens.
No questions asked.
Look, I realize.
Aliens are...
Some aliens...
Our people, too.
Who are you?
Let's see, let the popcorn touch me.
Like, they...
Okay, come on.
Come on, little guy.
Aw, did it.
I like the beams a lot more.
If I'm against, like, the real...
Lies!
Alright.
She needs to be corrected.
Take her to the recorrection facility.
How dare she say they're Petra.
They're aliens.
Alien, right.
Alright, come on, guys.
There you go, guys.
Like that.
Alright, we'll let these two fight it out.
This is the most intense fight I've ever seen.
Alright, who won?
Wow, the alien won.
Okay, I have one bullet.
There must be another gun here.
Yeah, there you go
Okay, the aliens know how to flank now
Oh All right, we need another gun soon Got another gun.
You know fuck this guy in particular?
There you go I'm here.
Is it not here?
Where the fuck?
Oh, it's up here.
Okay, there was another stair.
Alright, we're just gonna wait a little bit.
Let them fight it out.
Except for that guy.
Fuck that guy, in particular.
Fuck that tumor.
Okay, I need a new gun.
I don't like these guns against the...
Yeah, no, tumors do not get to fight here.
Where are the...
Oh, shit!
Oh, okay, we're fine.
We're fine.
Oh, we're so healthy.
We were no longer healthy.
Okay.
Let's grab this gun.
Wait, no, there was a carbine here.
I don't remember.
Where the fuck did I... Okay, there's the carbine.
Alright, my 10-bullet carbine.
Oh, yeah, these were explosives.
I forgot the explosion.
Does that make sense?
It's just like, how the fuck did I explode?
It's because I shot, I literally shot the...
Oh, I'm sorry.
I'm sorry to realize my body touching it can also give a
nuclear reaction.
Oh, I'm so sorry.
But one little touch is all...
This is poorly designed.
I will have to save.
This is a poorly designed fucking...
Where are the safety protocols?
Where?
Will anyone think of the children?
There you go.
And they were very reactive.
But this little guy is shuffling over.
He's like, it's my...
It's finally my turn!
Okay, alright.
Oh my god.
Get out of here.
Where are you gonna infect now?
Are you fucking kidding me?
Okay, guys.
Guys, we all have a common enemy here.
We all have a common enemy, guys.
Come on.
Y'all hate this specific kind of alien.
Something's coming up to me.
Yeah, fucking, I saw you.
Oh, oh, it's just these guys.
It's fine.
Oh, nice.
These guys are so tiny.
It doesn't even take up my battery.
That's good.
Oh my god, look at him.
Shuffle.
Look at him.
Look at this little guy.
Shuffle.
You're gonna make it.
You got this little guy.
Come on.
You're gonna...
Oh my god, it's gonna be so funny when you explode on all of
them.
You got this.
Wait, wait, wait, wait.
Nope.
No, no, no.
Turn back.
I'm invisible.
There we go.
We have to watch from the distance.
You're gonna make it.
You're gonna prove them all wrong.
You're so...
Okay, he's dead.
He's dead.
Alright, don't worry.
I got you.
Unfortunately, he died.
That's wrecking right.
Says the traitor.
The traitor says what?
There you go.
Okay.
he fulfilled his purpose he exploded
arbiter Muffets lead me to slaughter who has taught you
these lies him Oracle hello I am 343 guilty spark I am the
monitor of installation 04 my god of our halo how they would
sacrifice us all for nothing god damn oracle
okay how am i supposed to listen to him if he shoots me guys
only bad guys shoot first But I will make them see.
Look at that.
He's guilty.
He just started blasting.
Wait, but they're just holograms.
How am I getting damaged?
One hologram down.
stuff.
It'll just drop down any moment now.
Their prayer holograms, Tokyo.
Tell your friend.
There we go.
Where is he?
That's no fair.
The real one flies so high.
Wait, where's the real one?
Where did the real one go?
Try again.
I don't even know where you are!
Oh my god.
There we go.
Oh,
fly away!
Pussy!
Fly away!
By your royalty arbiter.
With a new command?
A new fleet?
or was it the promise their great journey
don't worry i prayed more than you've prayed guys i'm
running out of sword juice
that's looking right wait that's the real one
guess we'll never know Yes, we'll never know.
That's their fucking leader?
Oh, that was the oracle.
Wait, but we'll never know.
How am I supposed to get exposition or lords up if they
killed the lord?
Also, how the fuck did he get there?
Was he just watching me fight my demons?
So rude.
The lore is for heretics.
The real believers just listen.
Good aliens follow orders.
We're drifting.
Archer pods are cold.
I'll need to re-key the system.
Do it and find out where we are.
sorry for the quick jump sergeant you in one piece I'm good
yeah chief we're fine ma'am there's an object coming into
view now Cortana what exactly am I looking at that is
another halo oh say what tail drop I thought halo was some
sort of
It's Halo 2.
It's the second Halo.
Oh my god.
And in Halo 3, we find the third Halo.
Oh, it's all coming together.
We found Halo 2.
Oh, I can predict.
I can find, I know what's going to happen in Halo 3.
We're going to find a third Halo.
It all makes sense now.
And in Halo Reach, we reach the Halo.
We land on the Halo.
And in Halo Infinite, there's just...
It's all halos.
It's just every halo impossible.
It's just halos for days.
I cracked it.
I'm learning too much.
Mind the bump.
Look, how dare you spoil the game?
What the fuck?
Where did they get a Master Chief?
This is like a voodoo doll or like those little dolls to
scare children, being like, if you don't go to bed in 5 o
'clock at 9 p.m., the Master Chief's gonna get you.
It's like the Babadoo.
the fucking, what was it called?
Crap this.
I guess so.
Oh my god, he's so cool.
Oh my god, thank god.
I can stop pretending that aliens have rights.
Thank god.
Oh, it's these guns?
Give me a sec.
Alright, one of you must have my gun.
Hello.
Hey, hey, give me your gun.
Wait, no.
Well, not this one.
There we go.
That's my...
USA.
I'm gonna show them.
Show them how they're really used.
through military budget.
Ah!
What's my other gun?
Oh, yeah, it's the rocket launcher.
I was like, this is such a whimsy song for what I'm supposed
to be doing.
Alright.
It's fine.
What I'm, like, supposed to be doing here.
It feels like a fucking platformer game with this song.
It's like, Oh, my God.
That was, like, some crazy lag, though.
Oh.
I cannot see that.
What the fuck was that lag?
Oh, I'm sorry.
Was the grass too much for you?
Like, you know what?
There we go.
That's fine.
I won't need that, surely.
Look at that one guy in particular.
Oh.
Yeah, I don't care.
All right.
I miss being able to...
What?
Oh my god, I am.
I am the Baba Duke of this universe.
I...
Oh my god!
It's him!
I thought he wasn't real!
That's just a...
That's just a story a grandmama tells me.
So I'd eat my veggies.
He's like, if you don't...
Wait, did I kill him?
Oh, wait, it was my guys killed him.
It's Crapfish!
Should have eaten your veggies.
He's real!
Artillery disabled, Sergeant.
Wait.
Wait, that's a shotgun.
What am I going to do with this?
Alright, I got the shotgun.
Wait.
No, that's not a shotgun.
I was going to say, that does not look like a shotgun.
Never mind.
I was like, that's way too many bullets for a shotgun.
JK.
He's real.
The demons are real.
Ah!
I'm just going to...
Okay, I don't like that.
Alright.
There we go.
It's a little hard when I don't have the, uh, oh wait, there
they are.
Oh, there it is.
I wanted this.
Because I'm, like, trying to decide when to use my, when to
use my, uh, where did my rifle go?
When I want to use my rocket launcher and when I want to use
my other gun.
Oh, wait, but I need to use this now.
whoops okay who is it wait how did he get here wait how did
he get high ground where's my cover where did my cover go
all right that's fine oh he just gave up the door oh i
thought i had military troops covering the door
God damn, now the ship is attacking back.
Oh no.
That's not good.
That's fine.
There you go.
See there he is.
There's my guy.
My man.
Oh, I'm looking for you too.
I'll grab him.
I'll read him.
Oh, he's like right here some shit.
Where's the other guy?
I'm gonna shoot his legs.
Fuck it.
Come on, every time I scope in.
Oh, I'm stuck.
I'm stuck.
Okay, anytime you can help out, you know?
You know, you can help out too, buddy.
There we go.
Where's the last guy?
Come on, find the last guy, buddy.
Oh, there he is.
covering your back that's what you wanted oh now he's
covering my back how much ammo is this 51 I'll grab the 51
arm ammo everyone I should be everyone where
the fuck is the entrance to this I just found high ground
that's it he learned from last death.
Bound itself some cover.
Good for you.
Is there somebody's hiding?
Oh, it's up here.
It's up here.
Oh, there it is.
There we go.
I just gotta wait.
Not yet.
Why?
He's right here with me.
Another phantom.
Phantom?
There's more?
I don't see any more.
Oh, checkpoint done.
Oh, there's nothing on my radar.
Is someone stuck again?
Oh my god, there is another one.
Oh my god, it's another wave.
It's another fucking wave.
Who told me to go back?
Who don't need to go back?
Send me back to hell.
Oh, God.
The ship is fighting back.
That's not fair.
You send him out to die.
You don't give them reinforcements.
Fucking coward.
Oh, my God.
I didn't see him.
I didn't.
and fucking see him.
Wait, what am I?
Okay, here.
I can't see.
I'll fight back.
That's fucking right.
I can fight back, too.
I can, that's right.
What you're gonna do now without your stupid fucking guns?
Get out of here.
Get your ass out of here.
This is America.
I claim this for Earth.
I claim this planet for Earth.
USA.
Oh, shit.
Where did he go?
There you go.
Hold here until the pelican arrives.
The pelican.
We're super.
US, UN, a sea you wanna see all
right there you go nice reinforcements
here comes our ride don't worry i'll save this for halo 3.
don't worry yeah it's gonna be so useful yeah it's not as
catchy i got a good view coming in there's a big building in
the middle of this island's lake i saw it too it looked like
a temple if i were to make Maniac and I'm not that's where
I'd be I know we got to save it for the third halo that
we're gonna reach to because it's infinite
Oh shit.
Oh fuck let's fucking go
But oh
we killed all of you guys all right any minute now oh shit
nice wait wait before I go okay I sort of really want it
whoa it's like a post guy I actually want the sniper I don't
want the battery whoa it's like a post cat oh
I should have given him no it's fine
Covenant has control bridge tall you're going to try and
bottle us up on this side of the What do we do?
Thing he sees me?
It's alright.
I have so much belief in my driver.
That's what I see.
I told you guys!
Believe in my AI!
There you see?
Look at that.
So easy.
Okay, please tell me he's gonna drive away from that.
I don't think we're gonna...
Out of all the things I thought was gonna happen.
I didn't think that was what was gonna happen.
It's okay, it's okay.
We can dodge all of this.
We can dodge all of it.
We are Halo!
all right i'm gonna leave you guys and then i want to drive
get out of the car get out of the car you you go you go
handle this oh no all right all right shoot the car shoot
him shoot the car shoot the car shoot shoot the car shoot
the car shoot it shoot the car there we go good job good job
we did it we shot the car we shot it I got another car.
Alright, shoot him.
Now shoot him.
It's okay.
Apparently, as long as I don't leave the car, the car will
never explode.
I put so much trust in that knowledge to that one guy that
said that.
Alright, shoot him.
Come on, shoot him.
There we go.
We shot him.
Alright, shoot that one guy.
Alright, I'm gonna drive a little closer so we don't die to
that guy.
Take careful, mate.
We did it.
What is...
Oh?
Oh, whoa.
The one time I got...
I got out.
Oh, my God.
What the fuck am I supposed to do with that?
It's okay.
Now I'm just here.
Oh, my God.
I forgot.
Get out of here.
What?
That doesn't hit him?
Okay, that's bullshit.
Alright.
I'll just, I'll be this guy.
I'll just take the turret.
That's fine.
I just need him to...
There we go.
This is easier.
I hear- I see people below me.
There he is.
What the fuck is singing?
Down here?
There we go.
Oh, it's one of the priests!
Extendo bridge, though.
It's like their religion.
It's one of their prophets.
Now about those brave...
We are, man.
Who's gonna...
Regarding the history of the Covenant and its glorious
founding species, the San Shayum and Sangheeli, the record
of punished deeds would not be sufficient without a word on
the Arbiter.
That's me!
Not the consignment of shame that it is currently, but what
came before?
The legendary warriors of Sangheeli passed.
Oh?
Holy shit, that's badass.
Long before the covenant, the Sanghele ruled their world
with pride and vigilance.
Surviving the perils of both land and sea.
These were the arbiters of old.
Part king, part judge, warrior rulers.
religion took over right when we arrived on their frontier
world of olgathon the cost of life was severe led by a
mighty arbiter the sanghele resisted our entreatment with
ruthless force leading to decades of war those goddamn
prophets they ruined a good time can't believe it we were so
cool before to introduce prayers classic classic prophets
how did they win all they had were prayers they did we used
to be so cool true god these goddamn aliens ruining it for
the other cool aliens
and prayers they fucking win with thoughts and prayers what
the fuck gotta their entire the entire religion like from
the fucking arbiters was literally fight bnb cool while
doing it
how the fuck did the badass the goddamn badass war aliens
lost to the prayer All right, I got my tag.
Tag versus tag time.
Boom!
That's right.
My budget is bigger than your budget.
We don't need thoughts and prayers.
We just throw money at the problem.
Tag needs everything.
I can't believe it.
The profits are the...
Office erased the coolness.
I don't need an ally.
I just need a tank.
Allies?
Who?
Can't believe the Arbiter erased lots of that.
Faith is powerful, but tank is tank.
It's fucking right.
Let's go.
Oh.
Like, Caleb, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Unfortunately, ancient prophets had a forerunner
dreadnought.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
And Tank, we trust.
All right, nice.
Checkpoint done.
I can't fucking see shit.
I don't know.
Up or down.
I'm going up.
Yeah, that's good.
High ground.
Tank has high ground now.
Now, Tank is going up.
Holy, no, fuck it.
There we go.
That's right.
Try classic.
Oh, no, I like the...
I like those graphics more.
Alright, my tank will survive this.
What was this guy's plan?
That's right.
I'm praying your way out of this.
Okay, yeah, I'm going to use classic when I'm in this
fucking tunnel.
When I'm seeing that tunnel.
There we go.
You break it, you buy it.
Alright.
Yeah, but they have to pay for it.
Not me.
I just have to stay here.
I just snipe with my fucking tank.
How the fuck this guy survived this fucking entire shot?
Oh my god, do a flip.
It all did?
I can't tell.
I want to break this just to be sure.
Let me break their turret.
There we go.
Get out of here.
Wait, you're still alive?
I snipe this guy out of existence too.
that should be all of them he's him he prayed hard enough he
guys
all right let's roll over this puny goddamn shitty excuse of
a car all right he's still alive he was allowed he was alive
that all of them what the fuck is that over there in the
corner I guess I'll never know I blew it up oh it was a car
well it was like I said it was a car
but that's another car that's fuck it I'm just gonna what
the fuck what kind of car is that okay there we go I got it
I swear to God, that car survived like 80 shots.
Okay, down I go.
Hope you're having a fun, great time playing Halo 2.
Oh, it's my favorite game of the franchise.
Yeah, I'm having a great time, Shane.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Oh my God, what are the quads gonna do here?
Oh, you think this grenade is gonna stop me?
Yeah, we're gonna have to play it.
We're gonna play it with OG graphics here.
is the guys I literally can't see shit like here
oh my god these don't stop coming in don't stop oh you
thought you could roll away the cock runs for a reason get
over here
that's fucking right I like how that one grant just like let
me run them over like that like that was crazy i did not
think i thought he was gonna move away what flashlight look
at this i cannot see shit sometimes i'm surprised with how
much they're just chill like that it's like that penguin you
guys saw that article or that clip of the penguin that was
just like walking into the Like, just walking to his death.
They're like, oh my god, where's that penguin running away
from?
Like, he just ran into the mountains.
And then people were saying, yeah, the penguin just gives up
on life.
They'll just, like, just head into the, they'll just head to
the middle of nowhere and just to die.
And I was like, holy shit, what the fuck?
They're like, where is that penguin going?
Yeah, it just walks into the throat there.
And he just disappeared.
literally just walked into the frozen depths and then like
was gone he's just like I can't take this no more with that
front that stood still why they do that I think it's just I
think it's just a depressed penguin and he waddle the way
it's like I don't know why they did that I think it might
just be different depressed penguin.
I think he was depressed.
Call of the mountain.
The mountains were calling for him.
Okay, who's that shooting me?
That's anti- artillery?
Bro.
Gotta reinvest your pair budget.
Is that all of them?
Whoa.
One last cool explosion for the ride.
Alright, now I can see again.
You guys, you think my tank's gonna be okay?
My tank should be fine.
I'm having trouble starting to see now.
There's no very next day.
And he waddled away.
This is like, there's less fire in the OG.
oh yeah it's just heavy fire you're right it's part of the
tank design the place it's like when you when you put fire
we pay fire on cars to make it look like it'll go faster but
we have real fire so it'll go even faster pelican inbound
let's clear a landing zone
even faster guys.
That's what they don't tell you.
Dude.
Why is he still alive?
Hello?
Oh, there we go.
See?
The fire helps.
There you go.
Have we not cleared it yet?
No, that was... Oh, that was just parts of the car.
I feel like all I've been doing is... I've been shooting.
Oh, there they are.
There's the little guys.
Get over here, little guy.
It's not over till I say it's over.
Alright, that should be every... Oh.
Is that... Yeah, that's a good guy.
Alright.
Now we're good.
That's right.
We claimed this area.
Poor earth!
USA USA I
think I got everyone where else am I supposed to go now I
have to go up okay all right my tank and I have to go up oh
there it is there's the pelican no I say goodbye no they
can't do this I bonded with it.
We bonded.
God damn it.
Why can't they make, like, miniature tanks?
They're all pouring out of the middle.
Let's get in there.
The middle.
Oh, shit.
Don't worry, man.
I got you.
The tank is here.
structure oh they're still fine see i didn't kill them
all right all right
don't worry i'm here to help look at that i'm tipping the
tank is tipping guys the tank is tipping the tank
I did it.
I helped.
There we go.
Wait, I should actually start using this.
I'll flush it out.
Where is he?
Wait, how is there only one guy left?
What happened to the others?
They run away.
Those cowards!
I can't believe it!
He just ran away?
What happened to my other Marines?
Oh my god, the fucking cowards.
Can't believe it.
Ah, fuck this.
Okay, nice.
Oh, chef killed 5,000 enemies.
Okay, I need that gun.
Give me that gun to kill these guys.
There we go.
Get over here.
Get your ass over here.
Where's the last one?
Get your ass over.
Get out of here.
All right.
I want to test this theory.
Oh, shit.
Fuck that guy, though.
All right.
I need to test this theory out.
Take that.
I'm with you all the way, Chief.
Wait a minute.
What did I even do to you, sir?
All right.
Now shoot him.
Hey, you fellas better keep up.
All right, now...
Wait, it's still one.
Oh, let him keep it.
He's just gonna die with my gun.
He's just gonna die with it.
Oh, shit.
I interrupted their morning sermon.
But he has unlimited ammo!
Oh shit, nice.
That's actually good.
Got the guy with the sniper.
Are you fucking kidding me?
Holy shit, okay, maybe actually you're right guys.
Oh my god, it's the carbine.
I thought it was the JK.
Yes, it's my grenade.
I thought this was the sniper.
It was just the regular...
Oh, nice.
Where's he getting shot at?
Oh.
That's awkward.
Oh, hey, nice.
I got my ammo back.
Nice.
He reloaded for me.
Oh, that's awkward.
Hey, at least he reloaded the gun for me.
Alright, last shot.
Last two shots.
Oh, wait, nice.
Reload.
He had rocket ammo launcher in his pants, guys.
Oh, look at him.
He's so clueless.
Oh, look at this little guy.
Where's his gun?
Oh, that's all he was carrying?
Really?
No, baby didn't know what to do.
You always bring me to such nice places.
Where the fuck was this sniper rifle?
Oh my god, I can't even snipe.
Oh my god, it fell off the cliff.
Get this guy out of here.
I'll snipe him with my goddamn covenant rifle.
I don't see any enemies.
Okay, now I have a sniper.
I don't see anybody.
Oh.
Okay, get out of here.
You weren't supposed to live that long.
Bada-dum, bada-dum, bada-bum-bum-bum-bum-bum.
No scope.
Where?
Oh my god.
I don't know where it's coming from!
Okay.
Oh my god, stupid-ass shield.
Wait, is that him?
Oh, I see you.
I fucking see you now, bitch.
That's right.
Get your ass out of here.
Get out of here!
Cat fool me now!
Oh my god, it's the same area.
I don't know where that shot is coming from again.
Oh no.
Oh, I see him.
I get him?
I need that sniper rifle though There you go Oh Oh What the
fuck the fuck
Okay I don't want to waste
I won't waste my sniper ammo on this
Alright God, they're so fast.
They're so fucking fast.
They're so fucking...
Holy shit!
What do you mean?
There's 20 of them!
There we go.
Just fucking landed on me.
They swarmed me.
Where's the last guy?
Where did he fly off to?
Get out of here.
Get no scope.
Bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum, bum.
Got your ass.
Oh, oh my god, I hated it.
They shoot me one time, and I can't fucking...
I'm like, deskoes.
I hate it when that happens.
Oh, got your back.
Alright, nice.
Wait, that's...
ammo for sniper.
There we go.
Nice.
More sniper.
What the fuck?
Get out of here.
Okay, that was double heady.
Checkpoint done.
26, 70.
I'll grab the new one.
I'll refresh fully 100.
This is where I'm supposed to go.
There's a hole.
There's a goal.
Ooh.
I can't wait to claim this for Earth.
Still no word about it, Amber Clad and the Covenant title
man.
It's odd.
The Covenant know we made landfall, but they don't seem to
consider us a very serious threat.
What the fuck?
I am a very serious person.
I am the fucking Covenant's boogeyman.
The Babaduke.
They tell bedtime stories about me.
Oh, wait.
Why does he get a cooler helmet?
What the fuck?
Wait, that armor's sick.
I am the master chief.
Alright.
That armor's not gonna protect you for shit.
Oh, wait.
There's another one.
Watch yourself.
Honor guards.
Oh.
That's what they are.
I was like, sick-ass armor.
Too bad your fucking armor is just cosmetic.
It might as well just be cosmetic.
How fast?
He doesn't protect your head, apparently.
We'll grab the sword.
Yay!
Really is just cosmetic.
Wait, go back.
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
The prophet of regret is planning to activate Halo.
Again?
I shall light this holy ring, release its cleansing flame,
and burn a path into the divine beyond.
Pretty much.
Commander, we've got a problem.
So I hear.
But from what I understand, the prophet will need an object,
the index, to activate the ring.
I've located a library similar to the one you're activating
a second halo?
The rings work the same way the index should be inside.
I'll bet the covenant are thinking the exact same thing.
Then we better beat them to it, Sergeant.
distract your men and meet me at the library.
Yes, ma'am.
I'll secure the index, chief.
You take out the profit.
He's given us all the intel we need.
Oh.
Wait, did she just say we have to go to another library?
No, she didn't, right?
She's just...
She's just joking, right?
It was just a joke, guys, right?
Wait, right?
to know library i swear they should have just fucking had
this entire area guarded by the flies of anything i mean why
do they keep putting the key to the halo and the goddamn
library
you gotta stop putting them in the library oh Oh my god, I'm
lagging like, oh my god, oh my, what is, what is going on?
There's too many books in that library?
Is there, there's too many books or some shit.
What the fuck?
Everyone's got to die sometime, baby.
Like what is in the library?
Oh my god, get out of here.
Your friends are dead.
It's rendering every book in existence right now.
Like, what the fuck?
How am I lagging?
It's like the Alexandria Library.
You better pay your fines.
Like, what the fuck is in there?
Oh, oh.
Give me your fucking sniper rifle.
I ran up.
Oh my god, please!
What's this?
Okay, it's just a gun.
Oh my god, there's a lot of them.
Fuck it.
There you go.
Just for the sake of it.
Incoming!
There, I'm fine.
Where is he?
Where's that little guy?
Get out of here.
You think you can just nade me?
You really think you can just nade- Get out of here!
That's fucking right!
Get your ass- Oh shit!
It's surrendering all the- No, fuck it.
What the fuck?
That's some fucking insane shit.
Oh, goodbye.
Oh my god, what a hero.
She ran away to protect all of us.
What a fucking hero, guys.
Oh, seven.
She died for democracy.
I am wasting a lot of sniper ammo right now, but I don't
care.
I have two more shots.
What the fuck?
What's that sound?
Oh, it's a hyper bridge.
Wait, where did I get shot from?
Oh, here.
Wait, where is the sniper?
There he is.
Ah, fuck.
Okay.
That's bad.
Wait, we gotta...
all right if only i have a cloaking device there's no way
there we go i i knew there was no way i knew yeah there was
no way he killed shoot he hit those shots
that's fucking right they don't know what to do when a sword
comes running at them they never know what to do.
He always gets shocked.
Like, wait, is she running towards me with a sword right
now?
What the fuck is she doing?
He panicked and dropped his gun, too.
Yeah.
Oh my God.
Where is the goddamn ship?
Is this... That's not anti-air.
I mean...
Just hide here.
Wait, what?
What the fuck is that?
What the fuck?
Okay.
Alright, now I know what the fuck was that.
Okay, now I know.
Now I know what the fuck that was.
Oh, wait.
I'll wait here.
Oh, dog.
I don't know.
if he'll be okay honestly i maybe i can like look from here
let's see oh my god the protecting everything i thought my
military guy would be like somewhere else
fine there we go
there we go he tripped and fell that's fucking right i think
it's dumb that they you know they skin them alive they put
their weak point back here like just cover it all like why
covering 80 you could spend the rest of your prayer budget
covering 20 that's left
like who the fuck like what is this gonna protect you from
just point of giant square here they're made of words just
put a giant square in the back it's all whoops it's all
worms those goddamn dumb worms oh yeah there's the rest of
my men launching from the far towers big surprise it's full
of covenant reinforcements oh is that darn that looks like a
shotgun I don't need that I have to snip oh no I think the I
feel like the covenant sniper rifle is better so they can
breathe that's what the next four just poke air holes in it
poke poke an air hole that's not as big as a sniper bullet
and then they'll be five
just put some put some air holes not that hard oh my god
That's what air holes are for!
He can breathe through the air holes!
Okay, I have to kill this guy.
There we go.
One more shot.
Wait, which has more bullets?
That one.
Oh, that's just a carbide.
Wait, where am I supposed to go?
That's the library, right?
You criticize the aliens a bit too much.
Their whole philosophy is built on prayer.
They don't even have currency.
It's just belief and faith.
How did they beat the cooler aliens?
I don't understand how they beat them.
I don't understand.
I don't understand how they beat the fucking aliens about
war.
Let them take that more faith.
They prayed really, really hard.
This light couldn't have been formed by volcanic action,
which means it was either built this way on purpose or was
created by some other cataclysmic event.
I'm sorry.
Were you trying to kill something?
Oh, shit.
I was too busy.
Fucking chilling.
Oh, he literally, that alien literally jumped to his death.
Oh, my God.
There's just too many.
I
Whoops, oh my god, there's so many there's so many oh my
gosh, I've got the guns I should have gave it I should have
got the guns that they originally gave me give me your
sniper rifle
There we go All right, there we go
All right.
There's always been only one Marine, guys.
There's only...
They've only had one backup.
There we go.
Where about that guy?
What the fuck?
Did he just live that?
Oh my god.
Get out of here.
What?
Who else shot me?
Okay.
all right there we go oh it was the other sniper all right
come on come out oh there another oh fuck okay oh shit oh
that's where he shot me from oh fuck okay where's the other
guy where's the other guy Where is he?
Okay, give me your sniper.
Hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey, hey.
Oh my god.
See, you should have given me your other sniper.
There we go.
See, you wouldn't have died if you gave me your other
sniper.
Oh, sniper off.
There you go.
There we go.
Wait, I need to trade snipers now.
Alright, 94.
There was always zero.
I can't believe they netted and sent me reinforcements,
guys.
God!
I have to do everything myself.
God.
Rufus so stingy with their budgets.
I can't believe I had to fight the Halo all by myself.
He's up here.
No reinforcements whatsoever that they sent me.
There was always one guy and that's me.
What was that jumping for?
Oh my god, I thought he was dead.
I thought he was...
He was so low to the ground.
There's a submerged section that connects these towers to
the outlying structures.
Looks like we're going down.
Oh, we're going down.
Okay, there must be an elevator at the top.
Okay, down is up.
I fucking knew it.
Oh, wait, never mind.
What?
Oh, he's sleeping.
What's this?
Oh, wait, is this a...
Wait, is this an alien rocket launcher?
I think it is.
Okay.
Wait, where am I supposed to go?
Was down not up?
Oh yeah, that is definitely the alien rocket launcher.
Down is up.
Oh, my guy.
I want to jump down there.
Oh, wait, the elevator's here.
Nice.
I don't have to jump down there.
Yay!
Can I trade swords?
Okay, I'll trade you.
the rocket launcher and then grab that okay and then all
right there we go i've intercepted a secure transmission
from the threat carrier to something bad that's a rifle
right it seems to be a formal apology to the prophets of
truth and mercy apparently oh we're underwater the gun when
he attacked earth whoa why don't we just take their
technology Yeah.
That is pretty weird.
Oh, did they underestimate us too?
Is this Bioshock?
Because it's lame.
because their technology is lame
why the fuck do they oh it's here I was I felt like a bird
thing I was like where's the opening where's the hole oh
wait oh wait is that the no that's the car but
I was like I can't get out I'm stuck I'm stuck
how are you still sleeping all
right get out of here get your ass out of here
we done here yeah come on come on men on the bonga time gas
gas gas I don't like how open this area is that's what's
right give me your sniper rifle now we're real good
never mind never mind give me the fucking rocket launcher
give me the rocket wait where's up here
what how what how did he take all of that all right take two
give me a rocket launcher all right take two there we go now
we leave i can't one where is he all right give me that oh
my god oh my god why did you shoot me in the back
all right friendly fire okay that should kill him and then
you give me this and then we wait oh sniper neutralized nice
okay we do need that though
where where are you getting hit where okay okay that's
that's on you
that's on you that's on you that's on you what the do you
mean what what got him
there's someone over here There we go.
Oh, thank God.
Thank God this is only heroic.
Oh, no.
They're everywhere.
They're...
Oh, shit!
No!
Serpentine.
Serpentine, but hey.
Oh, God.
There we go.
Oh, fuck.
Oh, I'm stuck.
Where's my Marine?
Where did he go?
Where did she go?
She has the rocket launcher.
Oh, my God.
There's a sniper somewhere.
There's a sniper.
Oh, my God.
There's still the bomb.
Probably dead.
Oh, don't.
Oh, God.
Okay, I'm stuck in a really bad place right now.
I need to figure out where she died.
Why are you all grouped up here?
Like, what's the plan?
What the fuck is the plan?
That's it.
That's right.
Energy sword!
Okay, never mind.
Wait, actually, I think I actually do have the plan, though.
They're like...
Oh, no.
Wait, okay, now I figured it out after I realized, wait a
minute, I could just outrun this.
I figured it out.
I was like, wait a minute, I can outrun this.
My big brain.
And people say I've got a big head.
What did she know?
No!
How did she know?
Oh my god!
Serious, Serion!
How did she know?
No way!
Oh no.
She's reading everything.
She's getting my...
Oh shit.
Now she's gonna suggest me stuff to buy.
Did you turn your katana on?
She's gonna start suggesting me things now.
Be like, oh, it seems like you would want some...
Want some things.
That was the greatest timing ever.
Elijah, thank you for the super chat, thank you, thank you.
Where the fuck did my marine die?
She had the goddamn rocket launcher.
Wait, terminal.
Oh, hey.
I was just trying to find Cortana, like the Marines rocket
launcher, but instead I got Lord.
For generations, our holy arrangement put the prophets in
charge of religion and technology.
The elites led our military forces to convert new species
and find relics such as your Hano.
And these relics you sought, the San Shion, your prophets,
told you that they would lead Yes.
Transcendence.
Eternal life.
Their promises were endless.
We gave up our old ways to follow the Prophet's lead on the
great journey.
Gave up all of our history.
All of our traditions.
Not all of your traditions, it seems.
This arbiter you mentioned, hasn't that always been a
position of power for your species?
an arbiter was once the pinnacle of our people leader of the
clans and master of the battlefield but then an arbiter
committed heresy and an example was made of him heresy he
challenged the word of the prophets challenged how did he
lose they just sit on chairs they're leading the fat people
in Wally what a fuck is that guy that's not no profit so the
title of arbiter became a badge of shame for our most
spectacularly failed warriors oh yes they were accomplished
manipulators back before the firing of the array I see at
least that hasn't changed manipulators what and before
before when I will explain later right now I want you to
tell me everything you can of these arbiters.
What the fuck?
Wait, how did he lose?
Oh my god, there is.
I found it.
I knew... Guys, you no one believed me.
Oh my God.
You didn't believe me.
I knew it was still there.
I fucking knew it.
I knew they were still here.
Oh,
fuck.
Okay.
Oops.
That's my bad.
He lost this one.
What the point of having an alien rocket launcher?
If it doesn't kill aliens.
Oh, that's it.
Oh, it killed him.
Oh, nice.
There we go.
Fuck this.
I'm tired.
That's the boss right there.
Bro, he was wearing red!
Alright.
We're having a sniper.
Fuck this.
I have two shots left, but I don't believe in those two
shots anymore.
Okay.
I'm keeping a sword, though.
The sword is cool.
The sword at least actually one-shots.
It does its job.
Like, you're not invisible if you continue to shoot while
invisible.
Like, what is this?
Your guns still make light.
Oh, my God.
Come on, shoot your gun.
There we go.
Hmm.
all right that's it you deserve to get slapped there that's
right okay there you are oh oh i mean that works nice it's
not fair when i go invisible i okay where the fuck is the
door okay there when i go invisible i can't shoot
What the fuck gave invisible technologies to the grunt?
Like, what the fuck are they gonna do with it?
They're like tickle guns.
Regret's carrier just received a response from High Charity.
A very well-encrypted message from the prophet of truth.
Listen to this.
Your haste has jeopardized the fulfillment of our covenant.
Threatened our grand design.
That you shall be spared a public display of our contempt is
thanks only to mercy.
and his wise counsel.
Truth, mercy, regret.
Three profit hierarchs.
Killing regret should shake up the covenant leadership.
But frankly, it sounds like you might be doing truth a
favor.
What the fuck kind of name is?
Okay, we have to kill all regret, truth, and mercy.
I guess that's like their role.
Like one will regret, one will tell the truth.
It's like one tells lies and one tells the truth.
So one will tell the truth, one will give you mercy and the
other one will always be regretting something.
No mercy.
Ying Yang and the other guy.
He only has regrets.
Oh, shit.
There's two of them.
There you go.
Now there's none of them.
That one's fresh sword.
How is it?
percent charge what were you using i was gonna say how the
fuck is that 88 percent you didn't even get to use your
sword oh hey you're sleeping oh my god they're having
nightmare oh this loss oh this poor little crunch they're
having a little nightmare time don't worry you're gonna be
trapped in that nightmare forever you'll never wake up from
it too that's it jacquard i think of the super chat thank
you thank you what the fuck oh shit
every member of the covenant All right, no regrets.
That's awkward.
Great journey.
Doesn't he know what these rings do?
There we go.
We have one more bullet.
Alright, one more bullet.
Get rid of those goddamn bugs.
Alright, now I gotta figure out what to do.
no regrets how did it go through his fucking legs that's
fucking that's it that's it i'm spamming now in fact each of
these prophets are the opposite of names truth lies regret
regrets little and mercy has little mercy to be found
there's liars yeah thank you for the super chat you i'm
gonna start i'm gonna start fisting they're posers
so there are regrets
maybe it was maybe maybe they were right they're like what
the fuck
There you go.
Look, I thought I would- I thought I'd live, you know?
I was like, nah, I live, you know?
I did not.
What, what, what?
How is he still alive?
That's like 80.
I'm nearly out of fuel.
What?
We've secured the first tower cluster, so I'll set down
there.
Call when you're ready for evac.
Oh shit!
Let's go!
My team's here!
Let's fucking go!
Oh my god, thank god we have guns.
Thank god.
Okay.
We'll grab the...
Actually...
Now we'll grab the sniper rifle.
There we go.
Wait, who sniped here?
Oh, shit!
Triple sniper!
That's not gonna fuck us over.
Woo-ra!
Too many snipers?
Nah.
Okay, I think maybe this team has too many sniper.
Not enough sniper, if I do say.
Alright, now I'll take the wait, where is there?
There's sniper.
There it is.
I like their sniper more.
Trouble, brother.
Oh, shit.
There's more people.
How?
Okay.
And we have cover five.
Oops, I'll sniper.
Oh, I forgot that this doesn't do anything.
Are you more willing to try legendary with someone else?
Uh, it's a very different experience.
So, thank you.
Super chat.
Thank you.
Okay, the thing is, if, isn't it where, like, if they die,
we have to start all over again type deal?
Isn't that worse?
At least I could...
It'd be like your co-op player.
Yeah, so it's worse.
Wouldn't that be worse?
Sissy?
That's it!
Get out of here!
Wait.
Sissy!
No one calls me sissy!
That's just iron.
What do you mean I read the chat wrong?
I just asked the question.
I never played Legendary on co-op.
We've just been playing solo.
That's if you have the iron skull on the Rookie.
Rookie starts the mission solo.
Thank you for the super chat, Breezy.
Thank you.
Wait, how do I... Where do I go?
Oh, it's this way.
this way oh
nice wait what oh shit that's a lot of them actually a lot
of them that just stood there all right not very smart
though i will say do i shoot that ship do i have
anti-artillery here
I left my guys.
I didn't even realize they never came on the ship.
Is that a rocket launcher?
Where the fuck is a rocket launcher?
Oh my god, there is.
How?
He was literally in front of me.
Oh my god, I can't...
Okay.
That's good to know.
So where is it?
There it is.
Oh my god.
I was trying to lock it in.
Where's the other guy?
Wait, did I hit both of them?
Oh my god.
I don't know how.
But it acts as... It worked.
I actually hit both of them.
That wasn't even a whip.
Okay, now that's a whip.
That, now that one was a whip.
I thought it would lie it needs to be closer to lock it now
I know okay now I know where's the other guy see leaving
that marine there was a good idea there
cool guys don't look at explosions what okay there maybe I
should have looked maybe I should have looked guys what the
fuck what are you doing here
whoops that was an accident that's okay I have a sniper
cool guys Oh, it's also missed.
Oh, didn't miss that one.
There are people...
No, there isn't.
I feel like they're going to start coming out here.
Right?
Why are there turrets?
Because they're not going to pop out.
Oh, there they are.
There is the little...
guys I fucking knew it I was like why where else would they
go no scope all right there was one more sniper rifle up
here that they gave me no where the fuck's the sniper rifle
what the fuck were you trying to do hiding until now oh
Here we go.
Can't believe they still haven't sent me any reinforcements.
Oh my god, wait, that is a lot.
Wait, what are they all doing here?
Kill regret before it can stop us.
Kill regret.
No regrets.
We gotta do it.
We gotta destroy regret.
What the?
What?
What are you doing here?
Oh my god.
How is he still alive?
I didn't think he'd still be alive.
I was just shocked, guys.
I was like, what the fuck?
I was like, what is he doing here?
Can you blame me?
I was just so surprised.
Oh, God.
The fact that it hits me and my gun goes up too.
Tilting.
Oh, I mean, he's like turns around.
There we go.
What is that?
Sniper rifle?
The Covenant fleet has launched multiple waves of phantoms.
Too many for me to track.
We don't have much time.
Wait, that's not good.
That's not good.
I like that.
What do you mean?
There's aren't...
guards all over the place what do you mean by that okay
that's not an arm that's not an honor guard oh nice huh yeah
that's right honor can't protect you from nades fucking
right
all right that's just an entrance to nowhere i don't know i
thought it would lead me to somewhere else okay wait what oh
i thought wait what okay i I thought that was a sniper
rifle.
I always get confused.
They both have, like, similar shape.
What's Honor gonna do for you, huh?
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh.
That's right.
Because I don't know.
I can recharge my sword.
Wait, that's regret.
What?
I regret.
Wait, is he dying?
I can't tell.
Is he...
Wait, who's shooting me?
Oh, fuck!
That won't work.
Oh, no.
I have to do this all over again.
Don't... Oh, wait, no, I don't.
It's fine.
Be fair, these guys are like two shots.
I'm not as scared.
Eh.
Okay, for, like, one of the high profits, you get protected.
You got grunts.
Really?
You have grunts to protect you.
There's the target.
Take him out.
Oh.
Like, you really think.
Oh!
You're very insistent.
No, never mind.
Never mind.
He has more than just grunts.
What the fuck?
Why is this little shimmy that he's doing?
Never mind, guys.
He had more than just grunt power for this.
I underestimated.
There we go.
He really thought...
Okay, now that I know that there's a lot more honor, guys,
let me start chopping these guys.
Where are the honor guards hiding?
I need
to save my bullets for that.
There he is.
There's the target.
Take him out.
Alright.
Give me a sec.
I got chopped a little guys first.
Okay, I didn't think he would...
What?
He...
fucking straight!
Alright, there we go.
Now I can get closer.
Where is he?
Alright, come over here.
The great journey will not be postponed.
Did I kill him?
Did I kill regret?
wait where did he go where did it regret go oh shit oh no
like
where am I supposed to volleyball him to wait where am I it
um excuse you what do you mean it
No, I don't want to stay where I am
Me first Nice fight
Guys so dude
That's fucking right wait where did he go?
Get shanked!
Oh my god, it's too much for you.
You mean, I killed most of them.
Oh, watch this.
Your very existence offends me, demon.
Oh shit!
Get out of here!
That's right!
Nerd says what?
Nerd says...
Oh shit!
me first but where did he spawn where is he get
over here that's right get fisted nerd that's fucking right
no regrets no regrets
okay where is he
oh fuck okay wait i don't know if you know if i can even oh
fuck wait this is bad get out of here this is actually
really bad recharging recharge recharge
get fisted get fisted yeah it's okay right nerd yeah it's
okay right i killed regret
I can't believe Turkey is beating up a senior citizen.
Go read a book, nerd.
Pray this!
If your faith is so strong, how are you getting beat up
right now?
Watch out your prayers.
out from my fucking fence no regrets that's right they can't
protect you from these oh shit what the fuck god can't
protect you from these hands that's a gray
This is not your grade.
Caleb, thank you for the super chat, thank you.
Oh?
This is unprecedented.
You're unacceptable.
The hierarch is dead, Commander.
His murderer was within our grasp.
If you had not withdrawn our fathoms, are you questioning my
decision?
No, Holy One.
I only wish to express my concern that the Brutes...
the guard was a radical step but recent events have made it
abundantly clear that the elites can no longer guarantee our
safety what I shall relay your decision to the council it's
not the elites fuck you know half the team were grunts what
the fuck were you expecting you recruited half the body guys
were little guys the elites have threatened to resign to
quit the High Council because of this exchange of hats these
have always been your protectors these are trying times for
all of us even as the humans annihilation failed us that
we're sleeping might add the sacred rings racked our hearts
with grief putting aside our sorrow we renewed our faith in
the prophecy that other rings would be and see how our faith
has been rewarded hello its divine wind will rush through
the star wait is this a different halo it's the two halos
cuz there's two halos for ages we search for one who might
unlock the first one was the first halo this is the second
halo and with your help we found it with appropriate
humility we plied the oracle with questions and it with
clarity and grace has shown us is this halo 2?
you will journey to the surface of the ring and retrieve
this sacred icon with it we shall fulfill our promise
salvation for all and begin the great journey salvation once
the she was down we will head straight to the library No!
That's the library!
Who was it?
Who do you think?
The demon is here.
The demon!
Why?
Looking for a little payback.
Retrieving the icon is my only concern.
John Halo is literally the boogeyman that he told the kids.
Like, God eat your veggies!
Or John Halo's gonna come and get you!
Ha ha ha ha!
There are seven big halos.
Well, six.
Nine, four.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
That's right.
We're in the library section.
But future dokey is going to do that next week.
Oh, we're going to give the library the future dokey.
She can handle that.
We did, you know, we did three checks.
chapters we did three chapters i think that's good progress
gus thank you thank you watch your mouth toky you're
sounding extremely heretic right now thank you the super
chat thank you thank you tony thank you the super chat thank
you thank you was there some kind of halo too you was super
chat thank you thank you yeah i'm really sorry guys that um
i came to this stream late guys i next week i promise you
guys next week no late streams none i'm gonna start setting
up alarms and everything um but next week no late streams if
there what is a late stream you guys can get a punishment
but there it doesn't matter because there ain't gonna be a
punishment there but thank you guys you guys are being so
patient with me um very sorry again um i didn't think i
needed to set an alarm for today just because i was like
there's no way i'd been asleep 12 hours i was like i already
slept earlier and i don't know i i don't know i'm like it
was coming back from Japan like my sleep has been all over
the place so I hope by next week it gets a little better I
really do um anyway guys uh as always everybody stay
hydrated posture check get up and move around to get that
blood flowing and if you stand for me head to bed guys you
deserve it I'll see you guys next time everybody bye guys bye